many people trying to escape irma's path
are having trouble finding a way out
airlines have canceled more than 1800
flights in and out of florida and the
caribbean american airlines says it will
stop flying to four airports in south
florida by friday afternoon it is
canceled all weekend flights to and from
its miami hub with all the turmoil some
flyers are complaining the airlines are
gouging them chris van cleave is at the
philadelphia airport one of the many
destinations affected by the disruption
chris good morning
good morning for people looking to fly
out ahead of irma they're finding
limited options and in many cases some
pretty high prices now the airlines are
responding to that but so are local and
national regulators saying they're going
to investigate reports of price couching
1328 dollars for a one-way flight from
miami to hartford connecticut
it's a high price for some to escape
hurricane irma people are expressing
outrage over ticket prices on social
media on twitter this woman said a
flight from miami to phoenix jumped from
over 500 dollars to more than 3 200
bucks when she tried to book on a travel
website she later tweeted delta resolved
the issue with a quote reasonable fare
another posted a flight search showing
fares of more than a thousand dollars
from south florida to new york on
wednesday the backlash prompted some
airlines to cap the cost of remaining
seats on direct single leg flights out
of florida a flight out on american
airlines won't cost more than 99 dollars
jetblue also capped it at 99 or 159 with
a connection and delta 399 that is if
you can find an open seat these people
were some of the last out of key west
airport on wednesday i'm sad because
i've been trying to get the key west for
years but i'd rather be alive than you
know
if it's dangerous we have to go but i'm
upset about it while prices increased as
passengers rushed to book flights
airlines say they did not change their
fare structure explaining the cost of a
seat increases as flights fill up and
last minute tickets tend to also cost
more fares went up really quickly and
that's where you get the six seven eight
hundred dollar fares that people are
complaining about but at some point
someone maybe somewhere should have said
this is going to be public relations
disaster florida attorney general pam
bondi says she's making sure the problem
gets fixed i do not regulate these
airlines but i'm going to protect
floridians and i have the white house on
standby if they're not doing their jobs
but they're doing it
bondi says her office in florida has
received more than 1500 complaints of
price gouging in just the last two days
on everything from food to flights she
says she's also working with amazon to
try to combat excessive delivery charges
to people who live in irma's path gail
yeah price gouging despicable behavior
thank you very much chris feel for the
people who plan their vacation to
florida or san juan and then you get hit
with that and then you get price gouge
not nice thank you very much chris
vancleave